Reporter:
This is a question for you,
Alice.
Reporter:
What made you decide to direct
this film?
♪ When I was a child, running in
the night ♪
♪ Afraid of what might be ♪
I think the only reason to make
a movie is...
...if you can't help it.
♪ Hiding in the dark ♪
♪ Hiding in the street ♪
Alice Ginor, right?
♪And of what was following me♪
I've been wondering where you
went.
♪♪
(Melodic vocal)
Alice:
I read the script and uh,
I just didn't have a choice.
♪ Now hounds of love hunting me ♪
Alice:
It was an act of survival for
me.
♪ I don't know what's good for
me ♪
♪♪
(Melodic vocal)
♪ Oh, here I go ♪
Alice:
You don't believe anyone who
says you can have it all.
♪ Don't let me go ♪
Because you can't.
♪ Hold me down! ♪
Alice:
And sometimes people you love...
♪ It's coming for me through the
trees ♪
I'm sorry.
♪ Help me, darling ♪
♪ Help me, please ♪
Alice:
Sometimes the people you love
get hurt on the way.
(Knock knock knock)
Alice:
I guess it's all part of the
ride.
♪ Feel your arms surround me ♪
You can pray to God that it will
be worth it, at the end.
♪ Now hounds of love hunting me ♪
♪♪
(Tense music)
♪ Don't let me go ♪
♪♪
(Tense music)
♪ It's coming for me ♪
♪♪
(Tense music)
♪ Help me, someone ♪
♪♪
(Intense musical buildup)
Do you think it was worth it?
(Camera shutter clicks)
♪ Hounds of love hunting me ♪